hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one absolutely central theme of franz
kafka's short story in the penal colony
is that of justice and we might go a
little bit further
and say that the way that we're looking
at justice the way that kafka is leading
us to consider it in this scenario with
these characters and particularly with
this mode
of execution that is called the machine
is by viewing justice as you could say
paradoxical or incomplete
or even as in some respect
unjust and contestatory there's a
contradiction
at the heart not necessarily of justice
per se is a concept but certainly this
implementation of it and it is if we're
going to follow out that line of
reasoning
we should always remind ourselves that
we never really do encounter justice
in this world with a capital j as
something like a platonic form you know
maybe for platonus we can contemplate
that form of justice but even plato
thinks
that what we encounter within this world
is never complete or perfect justice and
it's always
materialized it's always particularized
it's always
within a certain system and so
kafka uses this literary
you could say device or setting of
a penal colony to to explore that
and a particular mode uh as it turns out
an unjust mode of sentencing
so we should begin by thinking about two
different
senses of justice within the penal
colony
so it is a penal colony right so it is a
place of punishment to which people
have been sent they might have been
soldiers or sailors
they might have been civilians and now
in the penal colony they are assigned
their tasks and
they have to do the things that that
compromise
the punishment from their their home
country
and there's you know some interesting
things that are said about this in the
course of the story
you know the explorer uh in the part
where
he says the explanation of the judicial
procedure had not satisfied him which
we're going to come to in just a moment
uh kafka says the explorer had to remind
himself
this was in any case a penal colony
where
extraordinary measures were needed and
that military
discipline must be enforced to the last
so we could say that there are some
things
within a judicial system a system
of not just you know set passing
sentence and
examining things but the penal system
that follows after that
where maybe rights don't have to be
respected to the same degree
or they can be narrowed or they can be
understood in in ways that on the
outside we would find to be
you know violations we say that
once somebody has gone off to this
you know to use a frame of
mind that comes from a different author
this archipelago
of penal
institutions systems i'm thinking here
about social needs and in his
labeling the gulag archipelago we can
also talk about in our own time
the departments of corrections and all
the other things associated
with them in each of our states here in
the united states and all the county
jail systems
those are places in which
things are going to be done a bit
differently and they're done differently
because you're dealing
with those who have been convicted of
some sort of crime
so is that unjust is there
justice involved there maybe in order to
keep prisoners from
you know violating each other's rights
you have to be very
harsh with them so there's that
but there's another very important
respect here
as well it's not just a place
of the condemned it's also a colony
so there's an entire community of those
who are
quite frankly stuck there some people
may have decided to go
to a penal colony away from their home
country
and endure you know all the things
involved with not just travel but being
in a place that's really
deliberately out of the way but not
everybody
would do that and there's a great scene
where
they're talking about the uniform of the
officer so he looked uncommonly
limp breathed with his mouth wide open
and had tucked two
fine ladies handkerchiefs under the
collar of his uniform right to suck up
the sweat
these uniforms are too heavy for the
tropic shirley said the explorer
instead of making some inquiry about the
apparatus and then the officer says of
course
washing has oily and greasy hands in a
bucket of water that stood ready
but they mean home to us we don't want
to forget about home
so there's this sense of being at a
distance being estranged from
your your home and being out there on
this what we might call a hardship
tour that could go on for for life
and there are not just officers and
soldiers out there
there are also all sorts of other people
they mention the commandant is
surrounded by
a whole slew of ladies
presumably the wives daughters
other relatives of the the men who have
been
stationed there some of whom apparently
seem to have some sort of rank so
justice both in the sense of being a
penal colony itself and justice in the
sense of a
community is involved here
what we can ask is whether the machine
and the commandant's old seemingly
popular
ways of dealing with things now fallen
out of favor
are are just or unjust
and presumably within this colony
although we don't get a lot of
discussion of this
there would be a important distinction
when it comes to justice and injustice
and when it comes to punishment so
there probably are some minor violations
or infractions because you know if you
think about the trouble that people get
into
you can't just be executing everybody
you wouldn't have a colony left after a
while so
presumably the new commandant
is you know taking charge of many of
these cases or perhaps the people who he
delegates and so there is non
you know non-capital punishment perhaps
corporal punishment perhaps
other kinds of punishment that have to
do with you know like
spending time in a jail or doing extra
work
we don't know because kafka doesn't tell
us in this story about
the rest of what's happening in this
colony
then there's violations of what are
called the
commandments and there is where the
officer
gets involved because the officer is
as he tells us a little bit later on and
again we don't know whether he is an
entirely
reliable narrative right so
he says here we go
this is how the matter stands i have
been appointed judge
in this penal colony despite my youth
for i was the former commandant's
assistant in all penal matters
and i know more about the apparatus than
anyone so presumably
if something is serious enough it goes
to this
this officer who has been there and is
sort of the stand-in for the commandant
and in that case it's going to be
capital punishment
and we can ask well is is that a fair
response to some of these uh infractions
for example the case of this
this man who is condemned who uh
did you know something wrong right he he
is his bed here we go
you wanted to have the case explained
it's quite simple like all of them a
captain reported to me this morning that
this man who had been assigned to him as
a servant
and sleeps before his door had been
asleep on duty it's his duty you see to
get
up every time the uh the hour strikes
and salute the captain's door
not an exacting duty and very necessary
since he has to be a sentry as well as
servant
and must be alert in both functions last
night the captain wanted to see if the
man was doing his duty
he opened the doors the clock struck two
there was the man curled up asleep
he took his riding whip and lashed him
across the face
instead of getting up and begging pardon
the man caught hold of his master's legs
shook him and cried throw that whip away
or i'll eat you alive
that's the evidence the captain came to
me an hour ago
i wrote down a statement and appended
the sentence to it then i had the man
put in chains
that was all quite simple
and so you know this is this is quite
extraordinary isn't it
i mean we have this case of somebody
who's supposed to be alert in his duties
and yet he's supposed to wake up every
hour or be awake every hour
and salute do this totally absurd thing
of saluting the the door the captain
apparently
wants to catch this person comes out
whips him in the face
and then the the person you know the man
responds to it in a way that shows that
he doesn't like being
whipped that by being reported
is a capital crime
in this this colony so you know
already here we can say this does not
seem to be particularly just but perhaps
we can look back
and say well you know it is a penal
colony they have to have strict
discipline
this person is a prisoner who's been
assigned some some tasks they did the
wrong thing
whatever we decide on that we can also
think about the justice or injustice
of the sentence what is this inscription
upon the body of whatever
rule whatever commandment whatever
infraction they committed so
and the the inscription is across a
narrow band of the body
the rest of the body is inscribed with
all of this extra
stuff essentially there to produce
pain and the person is is tied down
naked pierced by multiple needles they
make
you know more than one pass going deeper
and deeper
into the flesh over the course of six
hours
while people are looking on and you know
little jets of water are washing the
blood away
this is pretty horrific pain then uh at
a
time of you know six or so hours
the person understands the sentence that
is being inscribed upon their body the
commandment that they broke is being
tattooed effectively without ink on them
and supposedly there is this
dawning of understanding or
enlightenment that's taking place
the person uh sort of like the the
officer says
purses their mouth as if they're
listening but what they're really
listening to
is the piercing of their skin and then
a spike goes through their head and
they're killed
it's it's said that you know this could
take 12 hours
you know the machine would by itself
would take 12 hours to kill them instead
once they've attained that understanding
of what the rule is that they broke
they're killed and they are tumbled into
a
pit so this is the machine this is what
the former commandant
brought about as this new innovative
punishment for people and you might
say well this sounds horribly inhumane
and that's exactly what the explorer
thinks but the commandant and
the officer in the time that they were
building this devoting all these
resources to it
with many people according to the
officer flocking to see these executions
thought that this was an a way of
embodying justice
that had not been done before
and that was superior to other ways
of sentencing people and imposing
capital
punishment upon them so this is a
representation of justice which i think
we can see
kafka and the explorer and we think to
be
unjust almost some of you think that
this is actually
a good idea we also find out that
there's no
due process involved whatsoever
by design why not well we find out that
the prisoner
does not know their sentence yet why not
because they will find out their
sentence
later on so
here we go um he tells us
that the the explorer asks him how how
is this going to
to work and he says that uh
ah here doesn't the doesn't the the
prisoner
know their sentence no he doesn't know
the sentence that has been passed on him
no
but there's no point in telling him
he'll learn it on his body
he'll he'll be informed of the sentence
as the sentence
is occurring so the sentence itself
is you could say both means and ends in
a
a way that might be attractive to some
who love
consistency but this is you know this
goes against
many of the rules of justice that we
have and
he says that um he had no chance to make
any sort of defense he says
surely he knows he's been sentenced no
not that either then he can't know
whether his defense was effective
the officer says he had no chance of
putting up a defense
and then the explorer says but he must
have had some chance of defending
himself
and this is where he goes into his well
i'm the the person in charge
here and uh there's no point in allowing
him to make a defense why not he says
if i'd first called the man before me
and interrogated him
things would have gotten into a confused
tangle he would have told lies had i
exposed these lies he would have backed
them up with more lies
and so on and so forth as it is i've got
him and i won't let him go
is that quite clear now so
the the presumption there is that the
prisoner would simply
put up a bunch of lies based on more
lies as the defense and why
why does the officer view it in that way
well he tells us that his essential
guiding principle
is that guilt is never to be doubted
if somebody is accused they're guilty
they must have done something or
they wouldn't have been accused will
impose this
sentence on them which then makes it
seem
that the machine might be
you know even assuming that if the
machine was a fair way of doing things
big assumption there
might be in its application unjust what
if the
officer has somebody who is sent to them
and the report itself is false
and so they use the wrong commandment
well then this horrible suffering that
is imposed on somebody
and the understanding that's supposed to
result from it
are essentially meaningless aren't they
so this is a a big problem
interestingly the officer has
one further reason why it's okay for him
to do this this sort of thing he says
that
my guiding principle is this guilt is
never to be doubted and then he makes a
direct comparison which shows us that he
knows
exactly how things work in other places
other courts cannot
follow that principle why not
well because they consist of several
opinions and have higher courts to
scrutinize them
that is not the case here or at least it
was not the case in the former
commandments commandants time
right so there's no disagreement
possible
although there is now with the new
commandant and there's no
oversight there's no higher courts this
is it
there's no appeals process there's
nobody to provide
any you know questioning
or or oversight or
review so again we see that this
procedure here
is it really even appropriate to a place
that's a
prison colony or is this a type of
injustice masquerading as superior
justice
that's a question that we can ask and
this is all brought to a
crux in what happens in the final
part of the story which is
the sentencing of the officer himself
by himself when he tries to convince the
explorer you need to intervene with me
with this new commandant and make him
you know go back to the old ways
stop his interference make sure that he
realizes that this is just that he's
wrong about justice that we
are right about justice the we being a
singular
eye of the officer
and the maybe the ghost of the
commandant right
when the the explorer says what you're
doing is inhumane and unjust and i am
not going to
give a good report about this as a
matter of fact i think that you
are are you know doing this this awful
thing
and i will report it the officer places
himself
in the machine and he uses as the the
template for the calligraphy
be just so what is this implying
this is implying that he has violated
the commandment to be just
and that there has been some sort of
review process he put it in the hands
of the explorer who said you are not
being just and so the
the very article the the instrument the
machine
that has been tattooing again without
ink
all of these these commandments onto
people's bodies before they're killed
is now going to be turned
against the person who has been
administering these things
and he's going to suffer his own
sentence
it's also symbolic of course that the
machine breaks to pieces
in the process does not give him this
enlightenment
but does pierce him through the skull
and
kill him in a way that turns it into
mere execution without any of the
other things that he says are going to
happen of course we could say that the
officer
doesn't need to have this this
inscription tattooed on his flesh
in order to realize that he was
violating this commandment of being just
because he's the one who's carried
out the sentence but he is deprived
perhaps
justly of his enlightenment so justice
is not something simple and nor is its
opposite
injustice in this story in the penal
colony
you